ahora estamos muy listos para la tercera
ley de newton y esto es algo que
probablemente ya has oído en algún otro
lado pero en este vídeo me gustaría que
entendiéramos de qué está hablando
newton cuando dice su tercera ley y que
aquí está una traducción al español
directamente desde el latín y bueno aún
no diría porque del latín sí y newton
era era inglés pero en ese entonces
escribir en latín era común porque era
como como un lenguaje mucho más serio
aunque entonces la tercera ley de newton
dice que con toda acción ocurre siempre
una reacción igual y contraria quiere
decir que las acciones mutuas de dos
cuerpos siempre son iguales y dirigidas
en sentido opuesto entonces uno diría
bueno qué quiere decir esto de ahí vamos
a hacer un dibujo ahorita vemos estos
ejemplos pero digamos que tenemos un
bloque y si digamos que tenemos un
bloque
este bloque y digamos que está sobre una
superficie que puede ser como como hielo
digamos para que no haya mucha fricción
entonces más o menos ahí está este
bloque citó que está sobre sobre hielo y
digamos que llegó yo ok y quiero empujar
este bloque para moverlo ok entonces
digamos llegó yo utilizo mi mano
aunque ya está mi mano y lo tomo y lo
empujó para que tenga un movimiento
entonces lo que está pasando es que yo
imprimí una fuerza sobre el bloque que
va en esta dirección digamos en la
dirección hacia la derecha para provocar
que el bloque tome cierta aceleración y
se mueva en esa dirección ok entonces
eso eso es lo que hemos estado hablando
en otros vídeos pero lo que no es
intuitivo es la parte de la tercera ley
de newton en donde dice que no sólo voy
a imprimirle una fuerza a este bloque
sino que también el bloque el bloque va
a imprimir una fuerza sobre mi mano de
la misma magnitud pero en sentido
contrario ok entonces esto no es
intuitivo porque a lo mejor no es algo
que no es como que podamos ver que la
mano se se va hacia atrás verdad por
efecto de la fuerza pero puedes sentirlo
cuando tú agarras este bloque y lo
empuja al final de cuentas
tú estás sintiendo la fuerza que imprime
el bloque sobre tu mano porque sientes
la compresión que hace sobre tu mano por
ejemplo
no sé si si tú agarras en este momento y
si estás sentado en un escritorio o
frente a un escritorio y lo empiezas a
empujar entonces es más déjenme déjenme
hacer el dibujo digamos que aquí está
nuestro escritorio y de hecho lo estoy
haciendo estoy mientras estoy haciendo
el vídeo estoy empujando lo con la mano
para poder describirlo entonces digamos
que tenemos aquí nuestra manita y
estamos imprimiendo una fuerza a la mesa
o al escritorio en esa dirección incluso
inténtalo tú mismo entonces mientras tú
le imprimes una fuerza a lo mejor si es
muy grande pues la mesa empezará a
temblar o a sacudirse pero lo que vas a
sentir en la mano es como la la mesa
comprime tula tu palma o la palma de tu
mano ok y esto en realidad es una
evidencia de que la ley la tercera ley
de newton es cierta porque de no haber
una fuerza sobre la mano entonces no la
sentiría
el tacto se basa a partir de la presión
que siente sobre nuestra superficie
sobre nuestra piel digamos ok entonces
si si no hubiera esa fuerza no lo
sentiríamos vamos a ver otro ejemplo
digamos este digamos que tenemos no sé
que estamos caminando en la playa a
quien no se le antojaría estar caminando
en la playa en estos momentos entonces
digamos que estás caminando en la playa
y ahí está nuestro nuestro zapato
nuestro tenis qué sé yo ok y estamos
caminando sobre la arena ok entonces
estamos sobre la arena que estamos sobre
la arena en la playa y por efectos de la
gravedad es decir la fuerza que hay de
nuestro digamos de nuestro pie al centro
de la tierra entonces nosotros
imprimimos una fuerza que es el peso el
peso que se genera por la fuerza de
gravedad nosotros generamos cierto peso
hacia el centro de la tierra entonces si
tú realmente crees en la segunda ley de
newton deberías irte hacia abajo y asia
y hacia abajo porque esa fuerza es
constante entonces estamos acelerando
nos hacia el centro de la tierra
todo el tiempo verdad sin embargo esto
no ocurre lo que está pasando es que
además de que nosotros imprimimos una
fuerza sobre la arena y que de hecho se
va a mover verdad se va a mover porque a
lo mejor la presión la fuerza es muy es
muy grande y entonces aquí dejamos
nuestra huella pero lo que está
ocurriendo también es que el suelo o la
arena está imprimiendo el área
el suelo al final de cuentas está
imprimiendo una fuerza hacia arriba
sobre nuestro pie y esto ocurre para que
no sigamos acelerando nos hacia el
centro de la tierra de forma indefinida
muy bien entonces esta fuerza existe
para que nosotros o bueno esta fuerza
existe y eso justifica porque nosotros
nos quedamos quietos cuando estamos
parados y no nos aceleramos hasta el
centro de la tierra de forma indefinida
y entonces vamos a ver por ejemplo estos
estos ejemplos de aquí mejor aquí
tenemos una nave espacial y digamos
digamos que te encuentras en esta nave y
quieres escapar de la atmósfera
terrestre y por supuesto en el aire
bueno si en el aire no hay de donde
empujarse o no hay de dónde tomar
impulso así que debes tener los químicos
necesarios en este que es digamos
nuestro tanque de combustible debes
tener los químicos apropiados y para que
así se pueda permitir realizar la
combustión adecuada y qué es lo que va a
provocar que se expulsen gases por este
lado se van a expulsar gases a una súper
velocidad aunque hay una vez que se
realizan las reacciones químicas
necesarias y se van y van a irse a súper
velocidad hacia atrás del cohete y en su
ejerce una fuerza entonces lo que la
tercera ley de newton nos dice es que no
sólo se va a imprimir una fuerza hacia
atrás sino que también se va a imprimir
una fuerza en sentido contrario y esa
fuerza es lo que
va a generar que este cohete o esta nave
espacial sea impulsada hacia el espacio
exterior muy bien eso le va a permitir a
la nave acelerar cuando no hay ni
siquiera de donde impulsarse el
siguiente ejemplo es por si algún día te
encuentras a la deriva en el espacio que
ojalá eso nunca ocurra pero digamos que
te encuentras a la deriva en el en el
espacio y sería útil tener algo para que
para que puedas cambiar tu movimiento y
no estés a la deriva por siempre
y por supuesto no queremos que esto
llegue a pasar pero pero digamos que
este astronauta de aquí a pesar de que a
lo mejor esté contento qué tal que un
día pierde la conexión con este brazo
que lo está lo está manteniendo seguro
entonces que pues la pregunta es qué
puede hacer este astronauta para cambiar
la dirección de su movimiento y bueno
suponemos que a lo mejor se le acabó el
combustible de su cohete oa lo mejor de
plano no llevaba cohete ese día entonces
qué es lo que puede hacer
lo que va a tener que hacer es buscar
algo algún objeto muy muy digamos con
mucha masa que tenga en su traje o algo
por el estilo de tal suerte que se lo
pueda quitar y aventar entonces vamos a
hacer un pequeño dibujo de qué es lo que
ocurre digamos que esta es la mano del
del del astronauta
son sus dedos
ok quizás parecen más una mano de
alienígenas pero no importa se entiende
se entiende la idea y digamos que su
mano ya agarró algo ya tomó algo no sé
algo digamos algo con forma cúbica ok
digamos que ahí está el objeto que pudo
encontrar el astronauta para lanzar
entonces cuando el astronauta lo lance
va a ejercer una fuerza hacia cierta
dirección d
para este objeto pero al aventar a este
objeto también se imprime una fuerza en
dirección contraria muy bien de la misma
magnitud entonces lo que va a ocurrir es
que el cuerpo de la astronauta va a
verse
el movimiento se va a cambiar por efecto
de esta fuerza que le imprimió el objeto
hacia su cuerpo ok entonces esta es una
técnica en donde a lo mejor puede ser tu
último recurso para que no te quedes a
la deriva y solo esperamos que este
astronauta pues después pueda aferrarse
o agarrarse a algo